thank you for inviting me and thank you
all for coming
so i'm going to start off talking about
famous problem the p
versus np problem and it's probably one
of the most famous problems and can you
hear me
it's one of the most famous problems in
mathematics and
this is proof that it's even made its
way into popular culture
debuted you can hardly see it but it's
got its debut here
on the simpsons where i guess homer
thinks p
equals np and here he is trying to
solve the or pondering the clique
problem given a graph on n vertices does
it contain a clique
of size say n over 2. and a clique is a
subset of the vertices of that size
where every edge is present
so in that graph that does have a clique
of size 3.
we now know from seminal work from the
70s due to cook and levin and carp and
others
that this is a very rich problem and
there's
thousands of np complete problems and
they're all
equivalent in the sense that p equals
np if and only if any one of these
np-complete problems
has a polynomial times solution so in
particular to study the p versus np
question we just have to understand just
have to understand if the clique problem
can be solved in polynomial time
and i like a paper that christos wrote a
while back
where he described the np completeness
problem
perfect timing he described the np
completeness problem
and he gave a bunch of reasons for why
it's so important and my favorite one
was it's
uh it's used allegorically i think i
have this terminology right
to sort of understand the difference
between difficulty
and easy and it's not just in computer
science and mathematics
but in all areas in many different areas
of science it's used this way
so anyways it's an important concept and
it's the basic question behind
a lot of what people do in complexity
theory and the reason i have this
picture up here this is from the globe
and mail
there was an article on the p versus np
problem a few years ago
in the paper and the reason i have this
slide up here aside from the fact that
steve has a different answer
than homer is that on the left here
there's a picture of a boolean circuit
and indeed boolean circuits is the most
common model
that's that's around for studying the p
versus np problem
so boolean circuit model is a
non-uniform model of computation and
that means you have
a separate circuit or a separate program
for every input length
so for the clique problem for example
you have to first of all booleanize your
input
so for graphs on n vertices you can
represent the input
you can look at the adjacency matrix of
the graph and you'd have n squared
variables
where a variable x i j would tell you
whether or not
vertex i is connected to vertex j in the
graph okay so you have n squared boolean
variables
and the inputs to the circuit would be
those boolean variables or the negation
of those boolean variables
and the internal nodes of the circuit
are boolean gates or an and
and it computes a function in the
obvious way given a 0 1 value for the
input to the circuit
you just bubble up evaluating the
intermediate gates until you get an
answer
okay and
to prove p naught equal np in this model
you have to show that for sufficiently
large
n that there's no circuit of size
polynomial in n
that computes the clique function okay
so for example you have to rule out
circuits of size all circuits of size
say n to the fifth or n to the hundredth
into the millionth
for solving the clique problem on end
vertices
so why did we switch to circuit
complexity i'm going to keep this brief
but there's a lot of reasons for really
loving this model first of all it does
solve the problem so super polynomial
circuit lower bounds
does imply p naught equal np and
secondly
because you have a different algorithm
so to speak for each
input length you can study the
complexity of finite function so
you can really study whether you can
compute the clique problem
on n equal million vertices you can
study
can you factor numbers of length up to 3
000. and those are interesting questions
in their own right even if
the clique problem can't be solved in
polynomial time for all n
we really might you know the world is
finite so it matters what happens for
large but finite values of n and then
two other reasons that are
deeper and i'm not going to explain the
proofs today
for what's interesting about circuit
complexity the third reason here
is more or less saying that in some
sense studying the circuit complexity
of np complete problems is a win-win
situation so if you prove a lower bound
a strong enough lower bound for the
clique function
you're proving p naught equal np and it
turns out that if you can prove
good enough upper bounds so if you can
show that all languages
that have exponential time algorithms if
you can show that all of those languages
actually can all be done with polynomial
size circuits that's another way to
prove p not equal np so this is sort of
surprising
so upper bounds implied p naught equal
np certain upper bounds and
what obviously lower bounds do and
lastly circuit complexity lower bounds
are very closely connected
to the question of d randomization so
that's the question of given an
arbitrary polynomial time algorithm
that can flip coins can you de-randomize
it
and that's a you know fascinating
question that the complexity theory has
been studying
for the last 20 or 30 years and we now
know that it's
very very closely connected to proving
certain circuit lower bounds
okay
okay so short brief history of time
we had some fabulous results in the 80s
two notable ones are monotone circuit
bounds for the clique
function by raspberry and a monotone
circuit
is a circuit with the restriction that
the inputs have to be just positive so
you can't have any negated variables
okay and if you're computing a monotone
function such as clique
it's okay you can study this model
because monotone circuits can compute
monotone functions
and raspberroth proved that really
elegant proof that
there are no sub-exponential size
circuits for the clique function
so in a sense monotone p doesn't equal
mp
okay in roughly around the same same
decade
another restriction of the problem was
solved the ac zero circuit
lower bound problem ac0 circuits are
again boolean circuits
now you're allowed to have negations and
the restriction here is the depth of the
circuit
so the length of the longest path from
the output to the input
is bounded okay
and you know these were some great
results there's others i'm just pointing
out these two i think they're two of the
more famous ones
since then um you know we don't know how
to prove p naught equal np since then
people have identified some really
uh some sub problems that in and of
themselves are really
great sub problems interesting in their
own right and you have to solve these
sub problems in order to solve
in order to prove super polynomial
circuit lower bounds
and i'll tell you more about these later
but what i want to talk about today
is information complexity and
communication complexity and i want to
explain to you how
you can attack all of these problems
using tools from
information complexity and i'll leave it
a surprise which ones have already been
proven
using information complexity and which
ones we have we have a setup a framework
an information complexity framework but
it has yet to be carried out
okay okay so what i want to tell you
about today is
introduce these beautiful topics of
communication complexity information
complexity
it's a rich combinatorial framework it's
very easy to understand
there's some really intrinsically
interesting open problems in the model
and like i said on the last slide it's a
very powerful tool for proving lower
bounds
all of those three major sub problems
can be solved using
certain techniques from using
communication complexity
and at the end i'll tell you about other
applications outside of
lower bounds you know on the way toward
p not equal np
there's a huge array of applications for
communication complexity
and so i'll touch on those at the end if
you have any questions feel free to
interrupt me by the way okay so it
starts
really with a classical one of the
probably one of the most influential
papers of all time shannon's 1948 paper
called
a mathematical theory of communication
and in this paper
you probably know he defines the famous
entropy function
which intuitively is how much
information is contained in a random
variable
x and we now know that it's more or less
equal to the least number of bits
that are required to transmit a random
element from x
now communication complexity in one
sentence is more or less the
generalization
of this transmission problem set up to
the interactive setting
so in shannon's case messages were sent
you know
somebody had a message and they sent it
and in this case we're going to have an
interactive version of that so i'll
start with the simplest model the
two-player
model of communication complexity
defined by yao in 79
and we'll start with the deterministic
version which is the simplest
so you have these two players alice this
is her on the left she looks just like
bob but anyway that's alice
and that's bob on the right and they
each hold an
n bits boolean string okay and again
when you want to use this model to
compute a function you want to think of
a family of of protocols one for every n
okay so they each hold an end string and
their goal is to compute some function
f a joint function of their inputs x and
y
and usually you want to think about this
function as being boolean or at least
you want to think about the range of
this function as being much smaller than
the domain
okay
so one thing i want to point out is
one difference between the previous
slide and this one is now we're
interested in computing a function of
the inputs instead of just sending
the message that's sort of necessary
because if if all you wanted to do is
send your inputs there would be no
interaction needed so we're generalizing
in two ways we're going to
talk about an interactive version and
we're also going to generalize it so
that
they each have a bunch of data but they
don't want to send necessarily all of it
but they want to
you know learn they each want to learn
some interesting bit of information
about their
inputs okay so they a protocol
is basically an interaction between them
they have some fixed agreed upon
protocol
that involves somebody starting alice
starts she sends a bit
then bob responds with a bit and they
continue in this way until eventually
the last message
that's sent by the protocol should be
the output the value of the function on
x y
and the complexity of the protocol will
measure it to be
the total number of bits that have to be
sent
okay and the complexity is the
worst case number of bits the maximum
number of bits over all
inputs of length n okay and then you can
define the complexity of a function
to be the you look at the best protocols
or the protocol that gets the smallest
communication complexity and that's the
complexity of the function
okay all right so i want to look in a
little more combinatorial detail of what
happens
when you run a proto this is informal
when you run a protocol
to compute a function and to do this we
have to study we have to look at the
communication matrix
associated with a function so this is a
matrix
m sub f and all it is is a description
of the function that they're trying to
compute
so here n is three alice has an n bit
string
and on the rows are labeled with all
possible two to the n inputs for alice
and the columns are labeled with all two
to the n
inputs to bob and an entry like this one
i
j is just the value of the function on
this input and this input
okay so this is the communication matrix
associated with
the function and what we want to see is
what happens when you run a protocol
and we want to see that what happens is
this matrix is going to get partitioned
into pieces called rectangles and what's
a rectangle
so look on the bottom here a rectangle
is a special type of subset of this
matrix
of the form a cross b where a is a
subset of alice's inputs
and b is a subset of bob's inputs okay
and we'll see that when you run a
protocol a deterministic protocol
it's going to partition this matrix into
subrectangle
sub rectangles and then they're going to
be further partitioned into
subrectangles
until finally you end up with a
partition into subrectangles where every
single one
has always has the same value so it's
called monochromatic and then then you
know you're done and you can
give that answer so let's run this
protocol bob here
he's the first person that speaks so he
looks at his input
he is one of those y's and basically he
partitions his input into two pieces
whether or not he wants to send one or
whether or not he wants to send zero so
in this case
on his first two inputs he would send
one and on the other six inputs he would
send zero
that partitions the matrix into two
rectangles
and now on this side when it's alice's
turn she knows
she can see that bob sent the one and so
she knows that she's
working within this left rex within this
left
subrectangle so now she looking at her
inputs
partitions that sub rectangle into two
pieces
so say like that so on the
top five she would send a one and on the
bottom three she sends a zero
so that further partitions it into those
two subrectangles and now you can see on
the top one
it's they're all the value is always one
so here she can she's done
she can announce the answer one okay and
likewise on this path here
that's this is the sub rectangle
associated with this leaf
she's also done because this is zero
monochromatic so she can announce the
answer zero
okay so you just continue in this way
partitioning
you know bob speaks next he partitions
the other side
and something's wrong here yep
in any case when they finally finish
like i said you end up with a partition
of the matrix into monochromatic
each one corresponds to a leaf in this
protocol tree okay
and the number of so therefore the
number of leaves of the protocol tree
is equal to the number of subrectangles
okay
and if you might remember the
communication complexity of the protocol
was defined to be
the maximum number of bits that are sent
so that's the height of this protocol
tree
okay so because of that you can it's
easy to see that the communication
complexity has to be at least as big as
the log
of the number of sub-rectangles induced
by the protocol
okay and it's not obvious
but the other direction is also true
so this this thing what i wrote on the
bottom
and points out that the communication
complexity can be lower bounded
by by the number of you know if you
start with a matrix
and you know that every way of
partitioning it
the only way to partition it into
monochromatic sub-rectangles is big
that'll give you a lower bound on
communication complexity but the other
direction is also true
so these two concepts are more or less
within small
within small factors that are their
equivalents so if you have a
partition of a matrix into subrectangles
you can come up with a small protocol
for it
so that's why i'm going to show you this
picture this
this complexity class p to the cc
this is the communication complexity
analog
of the class polynomial time and it's
the set of all
functions f on x y that have efficient
protocols and efficient here is poly
logarithmic and n
okay and that corresponds to those
matrices
that can be partitioned into
quasi-polynomial many monochromatic
sub-rectangles
okay so this is sort of the
visualization of what
a function looks like that's in p okay
and i just want to point out one thing
before i forget
the beauty of communication complexity
is that it's really just about
messages information there's no notion
of polynomial time
there's no notion of computation the
players are completely computationally
unbounded
so alice can look at her you know when
alice
when they decide on a protocol and alice
decides whether to send 001
she can do something that's incredibly
difficult you know she can run and
double triple exponential time
doesn't matter okay so there's no
computational bounds
that's what's so beautiful about the
model and that's what is going to enable
us to prove lower bounds
okay so this is the class p and let me
just give you some examples to be a
little more concrete
so this is a very simple function it has
very short protocols
the parity function uh so now we just
want to the
x remember x is an n bit 0 1 string y is
an n bit zero one string and they just
wanna output
whether the number total number of ones
is even or odd okay and it's easy
because
alice would just compute the whether the
number of ones is even or odd send that
to bob
and then bob just adds that answer to it
to his mod two counts
so it's a two bit protocol so it's easy
it's in the class p
to the cc okay and now let's look at the
equality function
quality function x the quality of x y is
one
exactly when these two boolean strings
are exactly equal
okay and it turns out this is very hard
in the deterministic model and to show
you this i just want to convince you
that the communication complexity can
always
is always bigger than the log of the
rank over the reals
of the communication matrix associated
with the function
there we go okay and again it's just
because of this partitioning property
so we said before that if you have a
small protocol then you have a small
partition of the matrix into
monochromatic
sub-rectangles so that means you can
write the matrix as the sum
of all the one monochromatic rectangles
and each of the one monochromatic
rectangles has rank one
okay so that means the total rank of the
matrix can't be more
than you know exponential in the
communication complexity
okay and so because of that it's trivial
to see that equality is hard
because equality corresponds to the
identity matrix
which has full rank okay
okay so so far so good unfortunately
this model is not that
strong it can't even do equality so we
need a we need a stronger version
oh oh sorry i wanted to tell you about
the log rank conjecture it's a lot the
the rank lower balance the communication
complexity and a really interesting
conjecture by lovation stacks
called the log rank conjecture is the
conjecture that they're more or less
equal
so that the communication complexity is
polynomially related to
the log of the rank okay so that's the
yes
yeah so i don't know how far back i
should go but
um so we saw that if you have a small
protocol
then you have a partition into
monochromatic rectangles
so take all the one rectangles and
that's what this is this is a picture of
one of the one rectangles
okay and if you add them all up you'll
get this matrix
okay and each of these is a rank one
matrix
so that means that the rank of the
matrix is upper bounded by
the number of one monochromatic
rectangles
which is less than the total number of
okay okay so anyways the log rank
conjecture that's a beautiful conjecture
that's still
pretty pretty well wide open asserts
that the
the communication complexity is
essentially fully characterized by just
understanding the rank of the matrix so
said in simple
terms that's what it's stating that if
you want to understand the communication
complexity deterministic of your
function
all you have to do is understand the
rank and this is
really open um the best record so far
was a recent paper by shahar lovett and
he shows that
the communication complexity is at most
roughly square root of the rank
but that's quite far away from log of
rank
so i think it's a great great problem
okay now i want to move on
to questions
okay so now i want to move on to
randomized communication complexity
so it's the same as before but now we're
going to intuitively we don't want
we want the players to be allowed to
make some mistakes so we're going to
allow them
random coins so they're going to share a
random string r
okay and once they have that shared
random string r then they just run some
deterministic protocol
and now what we require is that for
every x y the probability that they give
the right answer
over the random strings r should be high
like 99 over 109 over 10.
okay the complexity is measured the same
as before
and this is the picture corresponding to
the class of functions that you could
solve efficiently in randomized
polynomial time
so it's a bunch of protocols so it looks
like a deck of cards
and each one gives you a partition of
the matrix into pieces
but now of course they might not all be
monochromatic and you're taking the
average
with you know for every x y or the value
that you're going to give it
you know if the probability that you get
it right is going to be
you know how many entries in the deck
get the right answer
okay okay so now we can go back to
equality and i can show you that
equality
even though it was very hard
deterministic it's very easy randomized
so this is an example of an x this is an
example of a y we want to know if
they're equal
i'm sure you can see that they're that
they're not equal but what the protocol
will do
given a random string r is it'll view r
oops it'll view r as selecting certain
indices
of one through n in this case it selects
three four
six and whatever the last one is okay
and the players each player given r
it computes the mod two sum of the
indices
that are that are pointed to by r so x
is going to compute the mod 2 sum
of 0 1 1 1 which is odd
and y i'll compute the mod 2 sum of 1 1
0 0 which is even
they'll send that bit to the other one
and they say yes that they're equal
exactly if the parity check works out
okay
so you can see that if they're equal the
parity check will always work out and
it's not very difficult to show
that if the parity that if they're not
equal with probability of roughly a half
this parity check will find the mistake
okay so it's very easy randomized it's a
constant bit protocol
so what's hard for randomized
the set intersection problem we'll see
is hard and this is the most famous
problem in communication complexity
it's the equivalent it has the
equivalent stature that satisfiability
has in the real world this is this is
the version
of satisfiability in the communication
world okay
and the problem is just you're given x
and y think of x and y as subsets of
n and you want to know if those sets
intersect okay
so more specifically is there an index i
where x i and y i are both one
okay so this problem we'll see it's very
hard randomized
and what's interesting about it is i'm
not going to define non-deterministic
complexity
but it's easy non-deterministically so
in the sense of
the players if you give them
they're short witnesses if i give them
the value i or if they guess the value i
it's very easy for them to check that
the strings
that they do intersect by just checking
that ice bit
okay so that's why intuitively this
function plays the same role of
satisfiability
in the communication world and that's
why it's such an important function in
almost all the applications
all however many of them there are
spanning lots of different areas almost
all of them
if you just know that this function's
hard and randomized complexity
you're good to go with the applications
so if you take one thing out of this
talk besides that p doesn't equal np
take out of the talk that this is a very
important function
okay in order to prove lower bounds for
set disjointness
sorry set intersection
um it's it's useful to use this
equivalent definition of randomized
complexity
and the equivalent definition uses um
von neumann minimax theorem
to change the quantifier order so here
instead of having a random string
there's a distribution mu over their
inputs okay
and the goal now is to compute f
x y with a deterministic protocol with
probability
say 9 10 with respect to this
distribution mu
okay and the theorem
which i which like i said uses this
minimax is that
f is easy to compute f is in bpp
if and only if for every distribution mu
there's a deterministic protocol of cos
poly log n
okay this definition is easier to use if
you're trying to prove lower bounds and
the original definition
is the right one to use if you're trying
to prove upper bounds okay so it's
easier
to construct a hard distribution and
then prove a deterministic lower bound
okay so in order to prove this lower
bound first for
set intersection there's a very long
history of really fascinating papers on
it
the first paper was due to kalyan
sunderland
schnicker and it did not use information
complexity which i'll tell you about in
a minute
and then there was that was a hard very
quite a difficult complicated argument
it was simplified by raspberry off again
not using information complexity
but the most beautiful proof that i know
of is the one by bjks
that's maybe 10 years old by now anybody
remember and this proof uses this
notion of information complexity within
which is another way to measure
the complexity of a protocol okay so
what is information complexity
it's again it's a measure of complexity
of a protocol so instead of measuring
number of bits that are transmitted
intuitively we're going to measure the
amount of information that the
transcript reveals about the player's
inputs to each other
okay so recall mutual information
between two random variables
is the average amount of information
that b reveals about a
or equivalently that a reveals about b
and
the information cost of a protocol p a
communication protocol p with respect to
a distribution mu on their inputs
is the sum of the mutual information
between x
and the transcript so intuitively this
is the amount of information
that bob learns from the transcript
about x
okay plus the other way around the
amount of information that alice learns
about why from the transcript okay so
this is just a great idea
to to might not be obvious to now but to
to define this measure of information so
instead of
measuring bits we're going to look at
what in order to compute this function
disjointness or whatever it is how much
information do i have to reveal to you
about my input do i have to send you the
whole thing
can i just send you a couple of bits and
it really is an essential
measure okay
and it's not hard to see that the
information complexity
if you get lower bounds and information
complexity it immediately gives you
lower bounds on randomized
communication because if you have a
randomized communication protocol
that sends b bits you couldn't have
revealed more than b bits of information
about x plus y okay so it's a
seemingly stronger notion and using this
measure
that's the third the third set of
authors here proved this result so why
am i highlighting this
uh this information complexity well
first of all like i said i think it's
just very natural
it's the measure that generalizes
shannon's you know concept of
transmission and like i said before i
think that the proof
for said intersection which was which
which came after some quite difficult
proofs
i think this proof is sort of the
textbook proof it's beautiful
and um it uses in a very natural way
just the properties of information
that you know that are so helpful so at
the core of the argument is a reduction
from the n bit intersection
problem to the one bit and problem and
that uses the chain rule
and the other nice thing about the
about the approach is that you can
actually get an exact well with a lot of
work
you can get an exact constant so we know
now that the community knows
because of this paper that for set
intersection
that the amount of information that has
to be revealed is exactly
this number 0.4827 n
and so other work kind of did other
things
so there's now been an explosion of
research papers using information
complexity
to prove new lower bounds and
communication complexity and basically a
lot of stuff that was difficult before
that we were struggling with
now has become much easier so somehow
it's the right generalization
in a lot of settings that makes previous
proofs previous proofs easier
and enables us to prove new things that
we weren't able to prove before
on the other hand there's a paper that
came out a few years ago
that basically showed that all the lower
bound methods that we currently have
for for proving natural lower bounds
that all of them are already strong
enough to yield information complexity
lower bounds
so it's an interesting situation if we
had directly studied information
complexity the proofs gets easier
but by not doing so we sort of tied our
hands behind our back used techniques
that were already strong enough
but that somehow made life more
difficult for ourselves
so this brings up another interesting
question open problem
are they the same so we know that if you
have lower bounds on information
complexity it automatically gives you
lower bounds on randomized communication
complexity but what about the other way
around
if you have lower bounds on randomized
communication complexity does that give
you
information complexity lower bounds or
set in a better way
if you have a protocol that has low
information can you compress it
to get a protocol that doesn't chatter
on and on okay that's can you compress
it to just
be sending you know the number of bits
that's proportional to the information
that you're revealing
and this theorem from a few years ago is
basically saying that the answer in some
sense is no
so there's a function on n bits and a
distribution mu
that requires exponential in k
communication
but the information complexity is only k
okay
so i think this is philosophically
extremely interesting
um it's really you know it's basically
saying that sometimes if you want to
do something and keep the information
cost low you have to chatter on and on
and on and it's
really surprising i think um just the
caveat is that the k
uh the the k is actually a very small
number log log log n so it's not the
interesting range of parameters that
were
that we want for the applications
and it's open to improve this for
for a function f for all distributions
mu it's also open
to improve this to a bigger k
okay so in the remaining time i want to
tell you about applications
and i'll first start off by telling you
about the promised ones
um so i don't know if i'll have time to
do all three of these but i'll tell you
at least about two of them and then i'll
give you a
quick summary of applications outside of
complexity theory
well still in still in computer science
most of them but outside of circuit
complexity
okay so the first sub problem is to
prove lower bounds for linear programs
so what do i mean by this
linear programs are one of the broadest
class of polynomial time algorithms
used to solve all sorts of optimization
problems
and we'd like to at least be able to say
that there's no linear program for
solving
clique okay rule out all linear programs
technically speaking if you could do
that you would rule you would be proving
p naught equal np
so you have to define what you mean by a
linear program
and yana caucus had a
defined it's a beautiful definition of a
very large class of linear programs
that he calls extended formulations and
let me just first of all give you a
little bit of background before i define
extended formulations
but i don't know if this story is true
maybe chris christos can verify but what
i heard
is that what happened and what led to
yana caucus's paper was that he
had been getting all sorts of papers to
review that claimed that p
equal np and essentially all of them
were very fancy linear programs
and he would have to debug them and find
the mistake and so he once and for all
you know debunked them all with his
paper
it's a great it's a great story and it's
even true
okay so how does one try to prove p
equal np um
well if you want to prove p equal np
with a linear program
you start off with your your favorite np
complete problem say traveling salesman
and what do you do well you try to solve
it by minimizing some linear objective
function that depends on your instance
subject to lying in the tsp polytub
what's the ts
tsp polytope it's just the convex hall
of all possible solutions so we have a
graph on n vertices
we want to know what's the smallest tour
through the graph that travels
that hits all the cities what are all
the possible
solutions they're all possible tours
okay so we have this huge high
dimensional polytope
that's the convex hall of these
solutions and we just want to linear you
know
minimize some linear objective function
that that involves our actual instance
subject to being in this polytube so the
problem is
that the tsp polytope is enormous it has
externally exponentially many facets so
if you were to
write down all the inequalities
corresponding to the polytope you'd have
an exponential size in
n you know linear program no good
so instead what you do this is what an
extended formulation is
it's you introduce new variables you
don't just stick with your original
variables you introduce new ones
and you try to write down the polytope
using the new variables more succinctly
if you can do that you've proved p equal
np okay
now just just a caveat i'm describing
a particular large family of linear
programs not
every family of not every linear program
but i think it's
fair to say that we don't almost every
linear program that we know of
this is the way it goes so what's what's
the reason
that this characterization is not fully
general is the polytope is defined
independent of the instance okay
so the instance is only in the in in the
objective function that you're trying to
minimize or maximize over
okay so in a picture so you start off
with a polytote p
defined by ax less than or equal to b x
is your variables is x1 through xn
that's x
okay it defines this polytope p down
here of course it's a high dimensional
polytope
i couldn't really show you that so this
is some high dimensional polytope
and an extended formulation of the
polytope p
is another bunch of inequalities e x
plus f y
equals g y bigger than equal to zero and
that defines a
polytope up here and you know in more
dimensions
and it's an extended formulation if
essentially it projects down to exactly
p
so when you project down to the x
variables you're right back to p
okay and the extension complexity of
this original polytope down here
is the minimum size of an extended
formulation and size can be measured to
be the number of new
variables these y variables that you
have to introduce
okay the minimum number okay
so what yana caucus did in the nine in
1990 this was
brilliant uh is he you start with this
ugly in my opinion geometric parameter
extension complexity of polytube how are
you going to study that
and he showed that it's equivalent to a
very nice
linear algebra linear algebraic notion
which is just the non-negative rank
of a certain matrix associated with the
polytope okay so he basically
made the job really easy if you want to
prove lower bounds on extension
complexity
all you have to do is study this this
matrix
s of p that stands for the slack matrix
associated with p
and all you have to do is understand its
non-negative rank okay so what's the
slack matrix
this is this is the poly tote p over
here okay
and the slack matrix you have one row
for every
facet and one column for every vertex
and the entry i j just gives you the
distance
between the jth vertex and the
i facet okay so it's called the slack
matrix because it tells you the slack
between
every two pairs
and the non-negative rank is just the
smallest number of non-negative rank one
matrices the thumb to m
okay so we've known this since the 90s
and the enemy caucus made
made progress on solving the problem by
proving lower bounds for the symmetric
case but it wasn't until
2012 that lower bounds on non-negative
rank and therefore lower bounds on
extended formulations for traveling
salesman and clique and other natural np
problems it wasn't until 2012 that this
was fully resolved and
the proof is is just information
complexity
it uses like i promise it's a reduction
to set disjointness lower bound
sorry set intersection lower bound i
apologize
in in the papers um the set intersection
problem is called the set disjointness
problem
and and i'm old old school so i'm going
to revert back
if i say intersection or just join us i
mean the same thing
okay so how does the proof go um
i really wish i could show it to you
because it's actually that simple
but basically you look at the they
started off by looking at the clique
polytope
and they observed more or less it's not
easy to observe because the clique
polytope is huge right
but they more or less observed that the
set intersection
matrix or our good old center set
intersection communication matrix
it's actually hiding inside the clique
slack matrix it's just there
if you look at the right vertices and if
you look at the right facets
it is the set intersection matrix okay
and because of that
they can you they could prove lower
bounds on non-negative rank
from so they follow from information
complexity lower bounds
for set intersection okay so that gives
you
a really amazing result that you know
that you can't solve clique
with a polynomial sized linear program
of this type
and then they used reductions to show
that the same thing's true for other np
complete problems like traveling
salesmen
and constraint satisfaction problems and
since then there's been a whole lot of
really interesting work
extending this proving stronger results
showing that there's no
extended formulations that solve these
np complete problems
even semi-definite program you can do
the same thing instead of linear
programs with semi-definite programs
and you can study their extended
formulations and we now know that again
these same
characters clique and traveling salesmen
we know that these same problems
also can't be solved with polynomial
size sdp
extended formulations and we have
lower bounds on approximation algorithms
even if you want to approximate the
solution with an lp
or an sdp extended formulation you can't
do it in polynomial time
okay and pretty much all of these
results use
tools almost all of them not all of them
but nearly all of them use
use the tools of information complexity
either they use the set intersection
lower bond directly or they use
similar ideas to redo the proof
i think this is a huge success story
no it's a good question i mean they do
and they don't
it depends how you formalize your your
np complete problem
so for some form of formulation
you'll get some results for every np
complete problem but it might not be the
one that you think is the most natural
yeah because the polytope is independent
of the instance
you don't always necessarily get uh
get the result that you were that you
were looking for
um
yes that's a good question
i suppose it doesn't directly yeah so
he's saying that you you can have uh
an implicit as long as you have a
separation or oracle that you can have
more than polynomially many constraints
and what does this have to say that's a
really good question
yeah you should work on it does anybody
know
he's going to say a different thing oh
go ahead
yes right
yeah i'm focusing on the p versus np
question for this talk but yeah
you're right
yeah so yeah i'll let
we can we can talk about that later yeah
so he's pointing out that there's
problems that are solvable in polynomial
time
with a linear program this is sort of
getting but you
but doing it this way will not will not
lead to a polynomial time algorithm
okay so next formula size lower bounds
so formulas are special types of
circuits where the
the gates the ore and and gates have to
have fan out one
okay and formulas are equivalent
so anything you can compute with a small
formula you can compute it with a
shallow
boolean circuit okay so formulas if you
want to
prove lower bounds for formula size it's
sort of like trying to understand the
parallel complexity
of solving the function okay how much
how long does it take you
to verify the answer in terms of time if
you had parallel processors okay that's
one way to think about formulas
and it's a major open problem to prove
lower bounds on formula size so forget
about circuits let's just try for
formulas
and formula size has a very nice
communication complexity
proving lower bounds for formula size is
equivalent to solving a really nice
problem in communication complexity
and this is an old result due to kashmir
and winderson
it's not typical problem that you
usually see it's not it's not a boolean
function the way we're used to it so let
me explain it to you
so the theorem states that the
depth of a circuit f is equal to the
communication complexity
of a corresponding search problem
associated with f
and like i said the depth of a circuit
the depth of
the optimal depth of a circuit for a
function f that's more or less the same
as the formula size
okay so what's the search problem
associated with the function f so f is a
it's not a two player function
it's an ordinary function on n bits okay
and the search problem associated with
it
is you have alice over here and she gets
an input x
that's a one of the function okay so if
it's the clique problem
she'll be given a graph that contains a
clique of size n over two
and bob over here is given an input y
and he's given a zero of the function so
if it's the clique problem
he's given a graph that doesn't have a
clique of size n over 2.
and their job is just to find some
variable
x i you know some variable
where their values on that variable are
different okay you know that you can't
be a one of the function
and a zero of the function at the same
time so there has to be a coordinate
where you differ
okay and that's the search problem
associated with f communicate
to find such an i okay simple and
they prove this amazing theorem it's not
it has an easy proof
that the this is equivalent so to solve
the circuit depth problem
all you have to do is get a you know
understand this communication problem
and i just want to point out that this
is why we like communication complexity
so much you start with a formula
and you want to prove lower bounds on
the size of it and that's related to
computation
and you end up with some problem that's
about you know information transmission
back and forth
and it's sort of you you're set up here
to sort of try to understand bottlenecks
and computation
without having to talk about time
complexity
okay so there's a monotone version of
the theorem that
restricts attention to monotone circuits
and again you can show that the monotone
the best monotone circuit for solving a
monotone function f
is equal to the communication complexity
of the monotone search problem for f and
the only difference
is still alice has a one of the function
and bob has a zero and they're still
trying to find a difference
but now we require that
that the that the coordinate where they
differ alice's input is a one and bob's
input
is a zero okay and if the function's
monotone
not only is there a coordinate where
they differ but alice's is one and bob's
a zero
so this is more of a requirement it's
easier to get lower bounds because it's
a
harder requirement to meet and
it turns out that you can prove lower
bounds again just
just a a a clever reduction to set
disjointness lower bounds
randomized lower bounce reset
disjointness um and it's still open to
prove lower bounds for a non-monotone
circuit so it's
open to make any progress at all on the
search problem in the non-monotone case
okay since i'm running out of time i'm
going to skip the last application
super linear circuit lower bounds we
don't even know how to prove lower
bounds for
general circuits when the size is
you know 10 n and the depth is
100 n and the depth is logarithmic and
there's
connections between circuit lower
balance and a really interesting
problem called the rigidity problem in
linear algebra
and those are connected to communication
complexity as well
i'll skip that okay so just to back up
i gave you my favorite some of my
favorite applications because they're
you know lower bound problems but really
this notion of information complexity
it i what i presented to you like i said
like it shows here is just the tip of
the iceberg
there's applications to all sorts of
areas streaming privacy
etc and i just want to show you in the
one minute
minus one minute that i have left a a
really kind of
easy intuitively application to privacy
um so differential privacy is a very
influential
definition of privacy that's been
introduced by several peoples including
cynthia dwarkus here
and i'm going to talk about a two-party
version of differential privacy okay so
you have
a player alice on the left that has a
database
think of the input x as a database and
you have a player
bob on the right who has a database and
you now you might want to think of this
as being a hospital database
and this is being a different hospital
in a database and they want to compute
as before some joint function of their
databases
and now of course we don't want anybody
in this database
we don't want that guy to learn about
any of this stuff and we don't want this
guy to learn about any of this stuff
but more but the definition of
differential privacy is a little
different than that
it's saying that if you if you change a
single entry
in one of these databases and you look
at the output of this protocol
so it's finally going to output an
answer that
that the entire transcript there's going
to be a distribution
on transcripts because the protocol is
randomized and differential privacy
guarantees you that if you look at the
distribution
for two different hospitals versus the
distribution where you change
one of the records by just you know you
just delete say one person's record
that the two distributions over the
whole transcript will be roughly
you know very close to one another okay
so
opting in or out of the database doesn't
change very much
what anybody learns okay that's the
essential definition
of of what it means for a protocol
two-player protocol to be differentially
private
not only is the output differentially
private but the entire transcript
can't reveal you know when you change
a database by one record basically what
you learn in a distributional setting
isn't going to change by much
so this is the formal definition but
it's what i said
so you have a protocol p that outputs a
distribution of transcripts
and like i said it's differentially
private if when you change
alice's so you look at a database x in a
neighboring database
x prime neighbor means that you just
change one record
that the distribution on transcripts is
within a factor of e to the epsilon
of point wise okay and same thing for
bob
and the connection is very simple so
intuitively
you should expect that if you have a
protocol that's low information cost
what does that mean that means you're
not you're not revealing too much about
your input to the other person
so intuitively that should mean that
you're more private
okay and this theorem that's more like a
lemma it's easy to prove
shows that if indeed you have a protocol
p
that's differentially private sorry i
said it the wrong direction a minute ago
if you have a protocol
p that's differentially private then
that means you're not revealing too much
about any particular input and therefore
you should expect that the protocol will
have low information costs i apologize
got the order backwards so using this
theorem you can prove
an and known lower bounds on information
complexity that i've been talking about
you can prove limitations of
differential privacy in the two-player
setting or multiplayer setting you can
show
that there's natural two-party functions
that can't be computed differently
privately and maintain low error
okay i'll
i'll leave you with that thank you very
much
in the differential private one yeah so
an example is
is a hamming distance so you want to
know the hamming distance between
so just view the database is a is a zero
one vector
and you want to compute the the hamming
distance between the two
so it is it is very natural
so there's there's two versions of
multi-party and i was tempted to talk
about
them but i didn't think we would have
time one version you just have lots of
players and they each
you partition the input into you know if
you have five players you partition the
input into five pieces instead of two
and
each player sees just their piece that's
called the number in hand model
and uh that model the techniques are
quite similar to the two player case
there's there's some applications where
you need to look at
the number in hand but mostly you get
the lower bounds from the two party but
there's another model which is called
number on forehead
where you partition the inputs into
those same number of pieces but each
player
has their input metaphorically on their
forehead
so each player sees all but its own
input
so it's it's a cool model and and it's
interesting because every
input bit is seen by more than one
person but nobody sees everything
it's much harder to prove lower bounds
in that model and lower bounds in that
model are
also connected to circuit complexity
thanks
yeah there's going to be some good
survey talks on some of this stuff so
if you're interested